what's happening you bad [__]
it's a new month
it's a [__] new week and we're ready
to rock the joint is brought to you by
blue chew joey what the [__] is blue
chew blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients
as viagra or cialis at a fraction of the
cost
now i'm 58 years old i get a hard on
maybe
you know i got a nice heart on but it's
not the hard one i used to be when i was
21 22.
blue chew is [__] tremendous you
could take it any time
day or night the process is simple you
sign up at bluetooth.com you talk to one
of the licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription
within days you're like joey but i i get
a great [__] heart out let me explain
something to you
you can never have a good hard on hard
lines are like money you can never have
enough money
you can't have enough blood in your
[__] dick you want them to call again
you want them to [__] tap
out and go to a [__] hospital for
treatment you blew up that [__] [__]
you understand me
that's what blue chew comes in try blue
chew for free with promo code joey
i'm gonna have you just pay five dollars
for shipping that's it just five dollars
for shipping
you can benefit from the extra
confidence when it's time to sling dick
and blue chew is gonna help they've got
a special [__] deal for you like i
told you
you're gonna get blue chew for free joey
what are you talking about on monday
morning free
free with promo code joey just pay five
dollars for shipping
that's bluechu.com promo code joey to
receive
your first month for free and as always
i want to thank bluechu for sponsoring
the podcast
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter listen
everybody is looking for [__] people
right now
you know i'm excited things are opening
things are open like the movies and
restaurants
but everybody's looking for a [__]
job you want a job
every place is hiring right now forbes
magazine says gyms hotels
and salons are set to go on an epic
hiring spree
in the next few months millions of jobs
will need to be filled
as businesses keep reopening how do you
hire people fast here you go [__]
zip recruiter try zip recruiter for free
joey what are you talking about you got
nothing to lose here's the difference
with zip recruiter you're not posting a
job
and waiting for resumes from joe schmo
to [__] come in
zip recruiter has tremendous technology
that finds the best people
for the job and it helps you get them
right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free joey
again it's [__] monday
you just gave me bluetooth pills for
free i'm with you with ziprecruiter.com
pressing joey that's ziprecruiter.com
j-o-e-y try it for free just by going to
ziprecruiter.com
the smartest way to hire let's get ready
for the [__] joint it's monday
morning cocksmokers
[Music]
it's gonna be a beautiful day
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 2nd of august another [__] month
flies the [__] by
unbelievable 2021
is flying the [__] by the numbers are
going up
but we don't give a [__] we're tight our
[__] vaccine is in
and we'll see where the [__] this takes
us it was a great week
i got my little heart monitor on for ten
[__] days
but i gotta tell you something ever
since they put the mother on my anxiety
has gone away it's the story of my
[__] life
i can test my blood pressure here in my
pulse three times a [__] day
i go to a doctor the blood pressure's
perfect the pulse is perfect
everything's [__] perfect
once you see needles and [__] in my
world everything goes away
it's amazing i go i have anxiety i can't
i can't focus i go get a needle
everything goes away i'm [__]
whistling in there i'm whistling [__]
dixie
feeling good the whole thing it was a
great week i want to talk to you a
little bit about
comedy today uh i did
ryan sickler's podcast a couple weeks
ago and i talked a lot about seattle
and let me talk to you about ryan
sickler's podcast whenever i'm
ryan stickler calls me or i call him and
we make plans to do a podcast
i don't really [__] know where we're
at till that day
i don't it's not like i prepare the
story for you guys
he tells me the night before and i don't
even think about it
i just show up that morning and work
from memory you know
and i watched a little bit of uh of his
part josh wolfe called me and he goes
that's amazing
that you remember that story it was
absolutely true you know all this [__]
but i didn't forget to mention a few
things you know about seattle and i want
to talk about them
i have a lot of young comics that follow
me a lot
i did not notice that a lot of young
comics are on patreon
and a lot of comics follow me and they
ask me questions
and uh i still talk to a lot of comics
you know established ones
and non-established ones that my friends
what am i gonna do
you know it's not like i don't talk to
non-established comics
and they've been telling me lately that
uh comedy clubs
have not really been really good to them
lately
uh you know comedy clubs make their
money off established guys you know
tom segura bird allie wong you know [__]
like that
rogan you know but those comics
are in arenas and in theaters so all
that's left
uh are you know non-established comics
trying to make a name for themselves
now one thing about me is i never forgot
where the [__] i came from i never
ever forgot and if you talk to young
comics
i've always been the voice of reason for
them if they have a problem they could
call me
we'll talk about [__] uh you know i like
the established guys
but i learned more from the
non-established guys the non-established
guys
are the ones that keep me afloat let me
know what's going on out there
you know i really really want to go back
out there
and just do little sets uncle vinnie
[__] like that you know but
and uncle vinnie and dino and uncle
vinnie's is one of the best club owners
you ever do business with
one thing i got to talk about him is
that i got to give him props
i enjoyed my little uh couple weeks down
there and when i go back when i'm ready
to go back
i'm definitely giving my loyalty to dino
he's he's a great guy
it's a great club but i'm hearing a lot
of clubs i used to go to
the clubs are turning on the comics
they're cutting their pay
they're [__] taking away bonuses you
know
half of these clubs got big-time loans
during the pandemic
some of them [__] stayed open because
they greedy [__]
and didn't give a [__] about you or your
family or anybody else
and if you went you know i'm happy that
you're still supporting comedy
but i wanted you more to stay away from
co-video situations and you could watch
there's a million [__] specials you
could watch if you need to laugh i mean
you know i'll watch rodney's specials
you know with [__]
sam and dice and all that stuff
but you know i i one thing i forgot to
mention
in that thing about seattle with sickler
was
how good the scene was to me you know
i was very fortunate i was very
fortunate trust me
there was a lot of comedy club and one
night
owners that were scumbags to me that
they were scumbags to everybody that's
part of the business if you're a young
comic you've already seen it
you see how you get treated they don't
give a [__] it's like being an extra
when you're starting out you know jiu
jitsu
jiu jitsu is a game of percentages and
they tell you that
a lot of people stay in jiu jitsu till
they get that blue belt it gets really
tough
after your blue belt you know now you
know what's going on you know what's
happening
so it's your ego now and a lot of people
just
you know if you make it to a blue belt
the odds are going up are not that high
it's a lot of people quit when they have
their blue belt i had to stop going
and i got my blue belt i just it didn't
work for me anymore
i miss it you know my knees are [__]
whatever
but it's the same thing with stand-up
if you could go past the fourth through
sixth year
seventh year you're in this for good
it's that four through seven year that
gets really hard
if you don't adjust it's going to get
really hard i know comics that have been
doing comedy for 20 years and never
gotten nowhere
i respect them because at least they
went up there and they tried it and they
stuck with it
that's the most important thing you
never know when that knob is gonna turn
and when it's gonna be your favorite
listen i never thought
it would turn for me and it did and it
wasn't a movie
it wasn't a set that changed my life it
was podcasting
because now people could see who the
[__] you are
not just judge you by your stage
performance you're telling them what's
in your soul
what's really going on with you and they
really appreciate that but
one thing i'm going to start doing is
i'm going to start every episode
especially when i do a comedy episode
i'm gonna i'm gonna thank the people
who helped me there were some really
decent [__] people
you know i got on stage in 91 and
i went to comedy works in denver great
club
and you know in 94 i got thrown out of
there you know i got asked to leave
because some managers said some [__]
about me whatever it didn't really
matter
i never stopped loving wendy and i'll
tell you why
most people were going you know [__] you
i didn't do that
with wendy wendy ran and still does
runs a great [__] club wendy is king
and let me tell you what she did when i
when i first
i don't i didn't really start my comedy
career i started in july of 91
but i didn't know what i was doing i i
really didn't and then
and i'm not mad at myself for not
knowing you just don't know
you just you're told to go up on stage
that's it i read some books i watched
specials i did everything i can
but comedy is something you have to do
from experience people could just tell
you so much it's like being a musician
people could just tell you so much you
have to get up there and do the [__]
rest so
wendy did something in 94 that i'll
never
ever take sides on wendy for wendy
put together she paid a comic
to sit with young comics on tuesday
nights
and go over the material and answer
their questions
i never forgot that that was aces in my
book the guy the comic who was doing it
his name was matt woods coincidentally
he was also the comic that was on stage
the headline the first night i went up
on stage long island guy
and he was the same comic in 93
that got in my face and told me how much
potential i had and whatnot so he is
very special in my heart matt woods matt
woods
jimmy bader and andy payton wendy
todd jordan rick kearns all those comics
and although you know wendy's not a
comic she's a club owner but they
really [__] helped me they nurtured
me the whole thing my feelings were very
hurt
when i got thrown out of the comedy
works i knew it was a business
i'm not that [__] [__] and i
didn't take it personally a lot of
people would have taken it personally
now let's talk about seattle what i
forgot to drop
i gotta dehydrate what i forgot to drop
on the ryan cycler podcast was
how special that time was for me you
know
if you listen to that story i got
arrested six times
you know this i took a gun out of a
cop's hole i mean it was a [__]
adventure but the comedy was so high
level
i think about seattle and one thing i
forgot to say on that podcast was how
thankful i
am to that scene i was involved with how
thankful i was to brody
how thankful i was to josh wolfe how
thank you know
it prepared me for la it was the next
level
you know right now you live in boston
right now you live in nashville
you know right now you live in
minneapolis you're an open miker
you're on that cusp you're starting to
get mc spots of the house of comedy you
know uh
you're doing one night is around town
maybe you're running your own night you
know
you're in you're in but there's always
one comedy club owner that wants to bust
your balls he doesn't like your material
and you know what man at that period
from four
at that period from four to six years
your ego is very soft you're not
uh you're still looking for an identity
up on stage the last thing you
need is some [__] owner telling you
you suck
you know which they will they'll tell
you to your face we think you suck
you're not good enough you know you're
not allowed in the green room they play
games like that with you
you look at them and you go you know
what go [__] yourself
you know i'm still a [__] man never
mind the open mic i don't need to kiss
your ass
i have a thousand situations where i
could tell you people told me
you're never gonna have a [__] career
if it's up to me and i'm like i
[__] you're down here in [__] dallas
in some [__]
back road in [__] dallas you're not
stopping me [__]
you know there was the guy from dallas
there was a guy from [__] san
francisco
that said if i said something to him
he'd never i'd never work in this town
again
and i told them all to suck my dick you
know me you know i told you
[__] i used to send out blank
tapes to [__]
i didn't give a [__] somebody asked me
for a tape i would send them a blank
tape how many people hired me and i
caught them in a [__] lie your tape
was great no it wasn't
there was nothing on that [__] tape
like i told you on the chair chelsea
handler used to send a porno
to people of her getting [__] on a
washer and dryer
you know on a [__] thing from the
side people were blown away they didn't
know what the [__] to say then somebody
tried the blackmailer years later
like hey we got a tape of you having sex
she's like stupid i sent it out
you [__] morons now go [__] yourself
that's how
creepy people are but you know there was
no
up and you know after about a year and a
half ago we had that thing with rogan
and the tape he broke and was laughing
and joey getting a [__] you know when
when all that [__] went down
it even hit seattle there had been
something going on at the coma comedy
club or something like that
and right away sexual tensions
heightened and they were looking for
stuff
listen when i lived in seattle i had a
[__] girlfriend you guys forget i had
a steady [__] girlfriend
and it was uh it was great you know we
had our little [__] situations
but even now whenever i talk to that
woman
i thank her i thank her we talk once a
month twice a month i thank her
for her time with me in seattle for the
support she gave me
because your ego is very [__] tender
you know i i shouted out laurie
kilmartin she was the first
headliner i opened for as a feature act
you know that
i i cherish those [__] memories but
the two guys i dealt with up there in
seattle the most were ron reed
with this guy carl wolmenhoven carl
womenhoven
worked the open mic he's not the guy i
stuck up for i stuck up for ron reed
but i would have killed from uh you know
for [__]
carl i would have killed for carl carl
took me from a to b when i got to
seattle
i used to do the open mics and i was the
number one i was number one i was the
first comic up when you don't have
experience
they don't know what you're about they
put you up first second or third
you get to go up there and bomb early
and really show people how bad you suck
right
so i did well so what they made me do is
i i saw myself go on the list
from number one all the way to number
15. that's what i accomplished in those
18 months
it wasn't me i i would love to say oh it
was me no it wasn't
it was carl and ron because after you'd
come off stage everything in seattle at
the time
when you live in seattle for comedy i
mean now i wouldn't live in [__]
seattle i don't know what they're doing
up there they got zones and
whatever but back then in seattle
even for me i had carl and ron
reed but there was a couple women that
were booking rooms
and they didn't dig me because of my
material
because of this that who we hung out
with i never
ever in all my [__] you know
20 whatever 30 years of comedy and 10
years of podcasting
did i talk about that woman she passed
away years ago whatever
she didn't like me she was joshua's
manager
she didn't like me but let me tell you
what i did i turned her not liking me
for you comics that are like well joey
how do you handle those type of people
you know that that are [__] mean to
you
you [__] with them you know you [__]
with them
when a book of tel used to tell me ah
you're too dirty
ah i don't like your style i don't like
this you know what
that's fine you don't have to [__]
pay me i'll do the set for free
and let the club owner decide and she
did not like that but guess what one day
i actually called her
and she said to me you know i don't want
to book you i don't like your material
i was like that's okay can i do guest
sets
and i would do guest sets in her rooms
on tuesday
wednesday or thursday she would sit
there like in her glory like i'm not
paying him i didn't look at it that way
i looked at it as i'm gonna get better
even though you don't like me
i really don't give a [__] you mean
[__] to me you're just in a little
pocket of [__] seattle
in the big picture you don't matter in
your mind
these comedy club owners think they
matter but in the big picture
they don't they can't control you they
can't stop you
they have nothing to do with los angeles
or new york
nothing if a comedy clone a comedy club
owner calls from
minneapolis to someone in new york he's
going to hang up on him i don't want to
hear from you i'm in the big apple
banging my head together
there's [__] junkies trying to knock
down my door and you want to call me to
tell me that i don't want to hire some
[__] guy go [__] yourself
that's never going to happen so don't
ever worry about that comedy club owner
in mississippi
or [__] uh you know
vegas or whatever they can't nobody's
gonna listen to them
trust me trust me what i'm telling you
i've told millions of people in my open
mic career to go [__] themselves
you could just take so much you could
just take so much and you have to have a
certain belief in yourself
and at that time i was stupid i was a
[__] junkie
and i didn't give a [__] i had one goal
in mind
30 spots a month that's all i gave a
[__] about
that's it i didn't give a [__] about the
politics of the club
who ran the club look at this guy he's
got a spot in the tonight show
that's got nothing to do with you the
only thing on your plate is where i'm
going up on stage today
and who am i what room am i blowing up
tonight
even though you're going to go bomb
trust me i was calling them bomb alerts
every [__] night i was bombing once a
night in seattle
it wasn't about the bombs it was about
getting on stage
getting on stage and like i said to you
i am so grateful
i could and listen there were a lot of
scumbags you know i had the [__]
booker from texas
i had the guy from cobbs that was a
[__] scumbag when you were an open
miker
they wouldn't even let you put your name
on the list he would come over to you
and point at you
you want to talk about feelings being
hurt and [__] like that
so you would get there to the open mic
and you go up to him like a gentleman
and go hi i'm [__]
mike schlotz you know i like to sign up
for [__] the open mic and he'd look
at you like you know really
okay and you could tell them whatever
you want i perform in seattle i
i'm a feature act yeah yeah whatever
they got their favorites
and they're there to irritate you and if
you have somebody call
like let's say you have me call for you
like the guy and i get along and i'll
call him and go hey my friend mike's
going up there tonight
to do five minutes they'll really put
you in the [__] ringer
they'll put you up last just because you
had a friend of yours call
that's how cold [__] blooded it was
up in [__] seattle all the other
[__] states i performed that
i remember going from seattle and having
a i was a feature act in davey florida
and it was how i met jimmy florentine it
was 1990 [__] seven
in davey florida and it's how i met jim
florentine i worked with the lady from
night court
i opened up for her and i'll never
forget i was a feature act i was doing
spots at the [__] store
i went to florida for 400 bucks
for six shows 400 it covers the plane
ticket and a grammar blow
and you're [__] broke and i did it
400 bucks
going to florida in 1997.
and you know what she was a [__]
scumbag to me they didn't care but
that's what i'm saying
about today that if they didn't give a
[__] 30 years ago about you
can you imagine now after the [__]
pandemic
and i don't my whole point of doing this
today
is letting you know that no matter how
much of a scumbag these club owners are
it should not deter you from your dream
not even at all if you let them [__]
win
you're not gonna have a [__] career
if you let them get to you
you're not gonna have a career whether
it's a guy in the audience
a comedy club owner anybody says
something derogatory to me
i got my fireman hat on it rolls right
the [__] off
and i keep [__] going because i know
in 10 years i could call you and go hey
remember me you said i never amount to
nothing go [__] yourself [__]
you know that guy from san francisco i
talk about he [__] went up to ralphie
mae once and asked ralphie may
this is even after i was in l.a after i
was a regular at the comedy store
he asked ralphie why rogan brought me
and ari on the road with him
he goes i like two [__] bums i can't
believe
rogan brings those two bums on the road
with him
and i told rogan and i went up there one
time with rogue and i pulled the guy
aside
i'm like hey man i heard what you told
[__] ralphie what the [__] do you
think you are the guy's not even in the
[__] business anymore
so don't ever get like don't ever let a
comedy club i want to ruin your [__]
dream
or some [__] jerk off booker ruin
your [__] dream
your dream is solid you don't need them
trust me what i'm telling you i got into
altercations there was a chick that used
to run the funny bone
in idaho they used to wear like lisa
loeb glasses
and she thought she was [__] cool and
i remember one time i went up there like
in 98
to open up for christopher titus and
like two nights in i couldn't get coke
and i did like a [__] couple lines of
speed and i was up for three days
and she came up to me one day like on a
[__] friday
and she was like i gotta be honest with
you i don't like what you're saying on
st you know she was very like you know
she thought like if if you were anybody
you wouldn't be in [__] idaho
if you were anybody as a comedy booker
you wouldn't be in [__] idaho so do
me a favor
take your little [__] [__] [__]
glasses and go [__] yourself
you know she was one of those lisa loeb
not lisa loba
she was one of those [__] like you
know she was all duded up she would wear
the
shirt rolled up to show her little
parrot tattoo on her arm
like i'm supposed to be impressed you
would wear different hats there was a
chinese chick
at the cleveland improv she was hotter
than [__]
sarah night hotter than [__]
that [__] didn't get dick she was
getting [__] by somebody with a little
dick
she was the most evil [__] in
the world
i'll never forget that [__] she got out
of the business i'm telling you half
these people got out of business they
don't matter
they don't [__] matter if you're a
young comic
look at them go okay good and steamroll
them
you keep going out and you keep getting
better don't let them deter you
any club you start at any club you start
at like if you
okay for example i started in denver
okay
the comedy works like me i could always
work the comedy works then they [__]
banned me
but there was two other clubs in denver
there was the comedy club that the owner
was great he recently died about 10
years ago god bless his soul he gave me
he helped me out a lot and there was a
club in westminster let me tell you
about life
i started at this club as a [__]
doorman
i went from doorman to sound guy and
doorman to barback sound guy and doorman
i did everything for them they loved me
and i loved them until
i got up on stage then they fired me
and for years i would call and go can i
work the club nah we don't like it
and my feelings would get hurt listen if
i could do it all over again
my feelings wouldn't get hurt don't ever
let your feelings get hurt
because the club says he doesn't like
you it's like anything else in life
there's 400 clubs 100 clubs
aren't going to like you don't take it
personal it's part of the business
150 clubs are going to adore you
and 100 clubs are going to be okay you
know in your world
but you got to understand if there's 450
comedy clubs
a hundred of them aren't gonna like you
okay who gives a [__] i still got my
[__] dream
i still got my [__] dream so who the
[__] are you
to tell me
i had so many [__] people tell me i
didn't have a career
i had so many [__] b listen the guy
from the laugh factory
when i got off stage the first night and
i love him now he's a great guy i love
jamie masada
but back in 97 you had to [__] wait
all day
you got to be there at six in the
morning and wait till six o'clock at
night
richard lewis would stop and bring you
waters
so for all you people who talk bad about
richard lewis
richard lewis cared about young comics
and he would say to us he would drop off
the waters on tuesday
and go i wouldn't do this if i was you
guys have a little [__] class but
you're too stupid
as a young comic you don't understand
where he's coming from
me if i could do it again i would have
done it again it was a great
12 hours to stand out there i got to see
what other young comics were thinking
how confused comics were how
i'll never forget there was one guy out
there this is the i got the l.a on a on
a monday night
i went to the store and on tuesday
morning i was told to go to the [__]
laugh factory
and i waited online with a dear friend
of mine from seattle the second day i
was in l.a
and there's a guy out there that knew
everything about everything you know
those guys they know
everything about it meanwhile he was an
open mica but he knew
everything about everything okay
he didn't shut the [__] up all [__]
day long i didn't say two words
i just kept my mind shut i watched and i
listened
this the comedy store the improv
this guy knew about every club every
booker
i was like wow this [__] guy is great
he didn't shut up the whole [__] day
loud
big guy sweetheart of a guy we became
dear friends later on down the line
sweetheart of the guy but that first day
he wouldn't shut the [__] up 12 hours he
didn't stop
guess what happens he's like number
three on the list they say his name he
goes on stage or suddenly becomes a
[__] mouse
you can't even hear me say me me me me
what the [__] you out there for 12 hours
talking [__] all day like you knew
everything about [__] comedy
and you get up on stage and you're a
[__] dunce he was like [__] he
didn't say a word he didn't get a laugh
and then years later he used to sell
cranky little trinkets at the store and
bracelets and
[__] like that nice guy sweetheart of a
guy he was from another country whatever
he was like an immigrant from another
country
great guy became we ended up becoming
good friends i forget what his [__]
name was but
you know he all day he's [__] talking
now it's time to perform
and he [__] shits to bed me i went up
then i did okay
and afterward you have to wait online to
get feedback from jamie
and when i sat down jamie's like i don't
even know what you're doing in l.a this
is my second day in [__] l.a not even
my full [__] day
i just get there and jamie says to me i
don't even know what you're doing in la
you don't belong here you belong in las
vegas
you're a club act you're not a big time
act how do you think i felt
most people would have folded up their
chairs and gone home after that
i looked at him i said thank you for
your input
i appreciate it you know if you don't
think i belong in your club
i could live with that it's not the end
of my [__] dream
and let me tell you what happened that
friday i talked to felipe esparza
and felipe told me to go to the brave
bull rudy moreno great guy
we're still friends we still talk on
facebook
rudy wouldn't call me back because rudy
was getting overwhelmed with phone calls
felipe said just go down there fool and
show up
and i went down in i showed the [__] up
and blew up the [__] room
i'll never forget there was a guy named
gilbert esquivel
another great [__] mexican dude he
pulled me aside he goes hey
what are you doing on monday night i go
nothing i'll probably go down the store
i got an acting class or something he
goes
why don't you come by the laugh factory
i go jamie masada
told me i didn't belong in the laugh
factory he goes [__] jamie masala he's
not there on monday nights
i run the show i'm putting you up and
even though jamie didn't like me
gilbert put me up every [__] monday
at 9 25 9 15 9 o'clock
i would get 25 i would go next door and
eat for like 10 bucks the sandwich place
and what was the you know so i didn't do
spots at the laugh factory during the
week
but i did monday nights in front of a
[__] great crowd
at a great time and guess what half the
movies i got on my resume
half the deals i got half the things i
got were from monday nights at the live
factory
so i didn't give up don't ever give up
as a comic
i don't give a [__] what anybody tells
you
you have a dream keep [__] pushing
and that's one thing i learned that's
what i learned in seattle
that nobody [__] matters in your
dream
not even me if you call me tomorrow and
go joey go [__] yourself
and i have the balls to say to you
you're doing in comedy
it's a lie there's nothing joey could do
to you there's nothing
nobody could do to you and if they do
what it's going to be some [__]
some [__] worm comic who's going to
call and say don't give you [__] work
well guess what
when you start selling tickets you think
the con you think the comedy club owners
give a [__]
why do you think i'm so [__] uh done
with this business because
for 10 years when i was opening up for
rogan they would pull rogue on the side
or they would pull me aside or they
would talk to rogan and not talk to me
and duncan
or they would not talk to me and ari or
they wouldn't talk to hari and duncan
people didn't really want to talk to us
they just wanted to talk to joe and that
was fine
your feelings get hurt for about a
minute and then you realize what's going
on here
and you [__] run with it and you look
at that guy and you go someday
you're gonna [__] pay me and someday
i'm gonna shove my dick up your ass
and you're gonna you right now you're
looking at me going joey how can you say
that about a comedy club owner it's the
truth
i had many a club owner that said [__]
to me
and guess what 15 years later
they were paying me telling me how great
i was i laughed
i took the check i cashed it but on the
way home i felt sorry for them
because they weren't really being them
you know there was a comedy club on a
couple years ago i'm not gonna throw him
under the bus
great club great city he told [__]
uh bert kreischer
that this podcast thing was only gonna
last for a year or two that he'd be
begging him to come back
bert's doing [__] arenas with tom now
but he told bert that bert told all of
us he goes this is what this guy feels
about you
nobody's ever gone in there to work now
he sends office but we all tell him to
go [__] himself
you know he was already back biting
already saying that
we weren't [__] that the podca re ain't
[__] you
okay don't worry about it and i could
have called them up and got on the phone
i did the theater across town and guess
what
at the end of the day they'll call you
and say can we come to the show and
you're like no
i'm not giving you free tickets this is
a great story jim florentine told me
that that [__] remember the time i
did the church and we were talking about
danny murr
had just died i think bert was on the
church meet burton lee and we were
talking about danny murrah
and i said rest his soul [__] [__]
sucker
anyway danny murr told jim florentine
he didn't want to hire him god rest his
soul danny murray he's been dead for
like [__] five years now
nice guy but [__] what a [__] puke
uh
[__] guy oh that guy was a [__]
puke
but you know he he wouldn't hire jim and
then jim went to do a rock club
somewhere and the guy called him and
said can you leave tickets at the door
and jim's like [__] no i'm not leaving
[__] for you
that's what i'm talking about that's a
real [__] comic
when you don't give a [__] like i said
the name of this episode today is
it's your [__] dream why are you
letting somebody
piss on your [__] dream whether
you're a comic
a musician a [__] a tap dancer a
stripper
it's your [__] dream how can somebody
[__] [__] on it
and even if they do push them out of the
[__] way
that you can't deal with that comedy is
hard
enough don't let anybody
make you quit this [__] game do not
give
anybody dissatisfaction trust me
when i told you guys i used to go home
at night and [__] cry when i lived in
boulder
i didn't cry in seattle by the time i
got to seattle i wasn't crying anymore i
would cry in boulder
because i really wanted it i knew what i
had wanted for the first time in my life
i figured out what the [__] i wanted to
do with my life
and i wanted to be so deep in it i
wanted to be so good at it i wanted to
put on such a [__] good show
i wanted every joke to bounce well guess
what my dream happened
it took 20 years for it to [__]
happen but it happened and that's all
that matters in my [__] world
don't let anybody piss on your [__]
leg
especially now you you know right now
we're still in a [__] pandemic
because everybody's still thinking like
that everybody's still thinking like
that when i found out that the comedy
clubs
were doing that to young comics and they
told me what clubs are doing it i'm not
going to call them out listen it's not
my business
i'm just letting you young comics know
that it's [__] open season on you
guys
and they're trying to derail you don't
let the money derail you
the money will come later do not when i
first got into comedy
there were so many people who made fun
of me under my breath like so you do
this for how much
fifty dollars ah if i did it i'd get
paid a lot more
i'm sure you would you know i'm sure you
would they couldn't get paid dick
you know how many people i saw even in
l.a
try to [__] say to me so you do
sponsor the store for 15
why would you do that
i'm going here tonight i'm making 150
god bless you
god bless you how long is it going to
last how long is it going to last you're
not you're not that good
they're blowing smoke up your [__]
ass that's how it starts
you know seattle was such a good scene
to me i was
very blessed and calmly i was very
fortunate and i'm giving the universe
thanks for taking care of me
because i seen it i seen people who got
out of the business
listen if you want to be in this [__]
business
find the city not la
not new york find the small city where
you could grow
detroit's a great place you know
utah has a great comedy scene texas has
a great scene don't move to texas to try
to get on the joe rogan experience
that's not going to work out for you but
texas as a whole to do comedy
you could get good quick in [__]
texas
everything has a time if you're a young
comic
everything has a time so for two or
three years
you stay in [__] your neighborhood
you know when i came to new york in 93
i didn't come to new york to be a comedy
star i came to new york to get my head
together to walk the streets i had
walked as a young man
to get strong again to prepare me for
the journey i was going to go on
i knew that when i came back here in 93
i went into new york i worked a little
bit it wasn't
i could tell i wasn't gonna stay here so
i decided
to just get strong take care of myself i
lifted weights i walked
and i studied comedy i went to comedy
clubs and studied it
i even trust me i was getting treated
like [__] at that time
i remember going to the comic strip and
they were like oh you want to get on
stage you have to sell tickets on the
street
and they would give you a book of
tickets so you had to come back with 40
bucks
you made you made 100 bucks but you were
gonna keep 50. you know what i sold the
tickets
i kept all the money and i never [__]
brought back that 50 [__] dollars
[__] them i bought coke with it you know
i didn't i didn't need to perform at the
comic strip that [__] bad
i took their tickets i'm like what am i
doing selling tickets for these [__]
jericho are you
are you [__] [__] joey i'm not
selling no tickets for these
[__] i took my money
i bought coker and i never went back to
the comic strip the new york comedy club
was taking care of me your old triple m
was taking care of me
there was a couple young comics that ran
rooms they were doing
rooms in north bergen there was a
restaurant on 69th street that did
comedy like on wednesday one wednesday a
month
i was going in there i found my [__]
thing but i knew i wasn't gonna stay
there
i knew i was going back to colorado to
try to be a [__] dad that didn't work
out but let me tell you something
those 18 months in colorado thanks to
jimmy beta
bill bower and [__] andy payton
those three guys i'm going to give them
[__] huge thanks
because they took me under their wings
they gave me work i was getting on stage
every night and [__] demon before i
left
the only thing that made me leave denver
was my problem with my ex-wife
i got a feature week in michigan at
joey's comedy club
i met the stripper i went back to
[__] boulder i made up my mind about
my future
she came by stayed with me for a week we
talked about seattle i made some [__]
calls
she went to seattle i went on a huge
[__] triple run for like five weeks
to make money
and i ended up moving up there with her
and i got there on a saturday night
and i was at the club the next morning
sunday at [__]
12 o'clock to see it it was closed i
went back monday i got on the open mic
night
and i pushed the [__] forward and yes
i had a couple [__] problems up there
but it didn't stop me from being a comic
and i'm very fortunate
that i went to seattle and i did it the
way i did it
i went to boulder i went to new york i
got awakened in new york
of who i was and what i was going to do
and that this is a real [__] business
you had to toughen up for this [__]
business this was not going to be a walk
in the [__] park
i've never said that comedy is a walk in
the park it's [__] hard
and like i said to you from four years
to eight is the hardest if you could
push through that
you're good to go i became a regular at
the store
after six and a half years was i ready
not really but i'm gonna tell you what i
had at the time
i'm gonna tell you what got me through
all those years my stage presence
my stage presence was second to none
from the very beginning
i knew how to lie i knew i'd listen when
you use a stolen credit card
and it's like an asian guy's name like
wing
and you go in there and try to use his
credit card you gotta act jack
you know what i'm saying you gotta like
like pablo escobar the guy that played
pablo white wagner mauro whatever maura
wagner whatever his name is
he walks fat like he's skinny but he
walks fat like he's fat
i've never seen that done before when
i've never seen that done before skinny
guy walk fat
if you watch narcos watch pablo escobar
the guy that hacks him
he walks fat he walks like he's 400
pounds
but he's really in [__] shape i mean
towards the end of season two
he gets fat he lets himself go they put
padding on him but don't believe the
[__] height that guy was such a good
actor
he walked fat that's [__] amazing
well
you faked the funk i watched
bill hicks i watched andrew i watched
kennison
i watch robert i mean i watched so many
comics and one thing they had was on
stage
they did not care they faked the funk
i didn't know what i was doing i had no
idea
but when i went up there i didn't fidget
i gave you the impression
that i didn't know what i was doing i
didn't touch the mic awkwardly my elbow
didn't go up when i picked up the mic
if you touch the mic don't let your
elbow go up that's your years of
insecurity
and that's your years of inexperience
don't touch that mic
don't touch it talk with your [__]
hands and that's what i did in the very
beginning i just copied that from other
people
it's not that i [__] invented it it's
not that i read it in a [__] book
no nobody [__] told me these are all
the things that you pick up in the
beginning to fake the funk
you know walk in the room like you got
200 000 in your pocket
meanwhile you got eight cents and three
pennies are [__] browner than debt
they're not even those shiny pennies you
know what i'm saying
they're those brown pennies that nobody
wants even the hindu at 7-eleven looks
at you when you give it to them like i
don't want this [__] brown penny
like that's how [__] brown the
pennies were i don't give a [__] how
broke you are
or whatever you walk on that [__]
stage like you own that [__] club
you own that [__] club don't ever
let anybody like people
always told me we didn't like him but
terry didn't like that i don't give a
[__]
you know what i'm gonna sell it to you
in a certain way you may not like my
material but i'm gonna sell it to you in
a certain way and guess what
i don't like my material either but i'm
gonna sell it to you tonight
i'm gonna sell it to you and you're
gonna pay me and that's the way it's
gonna be
so again in rapping don't let nobody
[__] piss on your dream as a comic
right now it's tough out there it's
tough in the world right now
it's tough all over getting a laugh is
probably a little tougher than it used
to be
i i i don't know i don't believe in that
[__] all audiences are the same to uncle
joey i never said to
you know in the beginning i didn't like
performing for people who had hair like
me like white-haired people i would go
[__] i hate these people
they're not gonna laugh i would i would
bomb before i even went up there don't
do that to yourself
i loved every [__] minute of it as a
young comic get yourself into a groove
get yourself with the listen i was i was
very fortunate that i had josh i had
tana manu i had brody i had there was
some comics that died from seattle i
forget what his name is he went on later
on and bought a club in lubbock he was
very good to me
you know you have to find your little
comedic circle
learn from them take from them don't get
mad at them
you know listen this is a business it's
not a [__] it's not a
you know if somebody doesn't pick you
for something
it wasn't your turn it wasn't your time
keep your mind open you know for years i
wanted to go to montreal
montreal montreal montreal they didn't
want me
i mean they were making excuses oh he
does this with his hand on stage
it's annoying really my little hand
twitch bothers you on stage
obviously we don't after a while give up
you don't need that [__] like give up
naturally i'll give you an example they
used to be a club catch a rising star
they used to be in reno princeton new
jersey and las vegas
the people who ran it were nice [__]
people
i sent them a tape and i called them
every
[__] day for a [__] year maybe two
years
maybe two and a half years i was dying
to work reno i was dying to work vegas
i was dying to [__] work princeton
well let me give you a story
princeton sucked i got into an argument
with the [__] guy nick
and he banned me from princeton i was
dying to do arena you want me to tell
high on to catch a rising star
three years i call that dude and if you
know anything about me
i will call you till you die change your
number or [__] hang up
and if you hang up i'm gonna call back
what i'm looking for when i was looking
for work
i didn't take no for a [__] answer i
don't give a [__] you're going to give
me work
i'm going to continue [__] torturing
you i'm going to keep filling your
[__] message box
and i'm going to keep mailing you [__] i
am [__] brutal when i was into comedy
when i was in that level oh my god you
would hear from me monday at 9 00 a.m
monday at nine you don't know how many
bookers would pick up the phone hello
joey d is here i want to know if you
have any availabilities this week and
they would go like
ah joey why don't you call me back after
12.
[__] you clock starts at nine [__]
i didn't give a [__]
i didn't give two [__] whether he was
sleeping you weren't sleeping
it's business time i never gave up on
myself
i didn't give a [__] keep calling them
keep sending them tapes i remember when
i moved to l.a there was this
there was this movie that marky wahlberg
was going to do
and it was uh vinnie curtis turned me on
to it it was vinnie curtis story
it was marky wahlberg and de niro was
going to play angelo dundee it was a
great story
and i forget that sheila jaffe if you
look at the sopranos
casting in la it was sheila jaffe
and in new york it was whatever
something walking it was christopher
walken's wife
she cast a soprano they were partners
sheila jaffe was in la she was one of
the biggest casting directors
doug when i found out about that movie
i would go home every night from the
comedy store do coke
and lick envelopes and send them out to
people i would lick envelopes lick
envelopes lick envelopes
joey what's licking an envelope you take
a manila envelope you put your resume in
there
with your bio and you write a letter
handwritten not computer written
handwritten and i'd also include
two tickets for four people to come see
me at the comedy store
i would send those [__] out
every
goddamn night to movie people
casting directors commercial agents i
didn't give a [__]
my goal was to send 10 envelopes a night
and i'll never forget
that after three months sheila jaffe
agreed to see me for one of the roles
guys i went in there and ate a bag of
dicks i'm not gonna lie there i went in
there
it was a slow debt but on the way out
i'll never forget her looking at me
going joey before you leave
hold on and she turned around and she
gave him back to me and when i say it
was a bag
it was [__] eight inches of head
shots bios and envelopes
with free tickets she goes joey uh i
don't need all these i was like holy
[__]
she saved them she didn't even throw
them away between me and you
collectively there had to be
30 headshots and i would send her a new
headshot
every time my resume would improve like
every time i added an extra credit
or a club to my resume i would send them
out to people
i was notorious for that [__]
sorry about that [__] lawnmower guy
coming monday morning early [__]
well anyway listen to me i uh
i just wanted to add on that seattle
thing that i didn't say with sickler
that seattle was probably one of my
favorite [__] times in comedy
it was a smart move i was up there for
two and a half years
i got my head handed to me a lot of
times but
sometimes you got to get your head
head-handed to you when you're in the
process
i'm very very grateful to seattle
as a comic today you know i don't know
what podcast i was saying that or
who i was talking to about it and you
guys know when it comes to ego that's
not my thing
but before the pandemic a year or 18
months
before the pandemic i was the best
that i ever was as a comic i probably
was a [__] up human
being the thousand milligrams of edibles
and all that [__] weren't helping me
i was a good husband i was a good dad
but i got to be honest with you guys
i was a great [__] comic up there and
you know i have a hard time i beat
myself up
i'm gonna tell you what i remember i
just remembered
wanting to go out there and i didn't
think about bill burr
i wasn't thinking about dave chappelle i
wasn't thinking about all the guys that
are funnier than me and all that [__]
i was just thinking about what i was
gonna [__] do tonight
and you don't know how many times i was
on stage and people were rolling
and i would say to myself quietly
this is from my days in seattle
these are from all the triple runs i did
now i'm starting to see it
like you know i would go on stage and
say to myself wow where did i learn this
these are from the nights i would do
jimmy abeda's rooms
like it was i was very thankful
for all that i suffered through those
years and it wasn't suffering
it was just struggling you're struggling
with drugs you're struggling for money
you're struggling to be the best you can
be
and people are trying to take you out
from all [__] directions and it's not
people it's just life
the way like this is comedy this ain't a
[__] you know
but i was very grateful while i was on
stage i would think back like where'd i
learn this from
and i would think back to my time at the
underground i still remember
on monday night that i got into a fight
with my stripper girlfriend
and she drew me out and i was so angry i
had one place to turn and that was the
underground
her and i had plans and i wasn't going
to go down to the underground that night
but i ended up going down there and carl
brought me up
and for some reason somebody had a
camera that night
and i remember they taped my set and i
against
everything i believed i went home and
took a look at that set and that
was the first time i learned to go off
like i went on stage improvised what i
was feeling
and i was like [__] i gotta do this more
often this
is [__] amazing i still remember the
sweater i had on
i had one of those [__] uh tennis
sweaters
that are white with the [__] lines
coming through it the last copy of it i
gave to rogan i did this uh
college film at the university of
colorado where i kidnapped the guy the
whole thing i still remember the
director
her name was kashina kessler
and i had it was a short film like a 10
minute film so when i got to l.a the
only thing i was sending out
was this set from seattle that was a
killer [__] set i don't know what i
was
i was talking about strippers i was
talking about you know
this girl that i was dating now she
threw me out and i forget the jokes i
said but it was the beginning
of my energy like it was the first time
i learned about energy like
holy [__] i raised my voice like i was
going on stage for four years just
being monotone and then i learned that
your voice controls the [__] room
that the volume of your voice
i learned that that night from looking
at that tape i was like wow i remember
sending that tape to latina lab festival
i sent that tape to a couple [__]
people i didn't get nothing from it
but i remember that that was that was
the breakthrough night
for me and it was like six and a half
years into comedy
so i just want to let you know there's a
bunch of guys on patreon sam
he's a doorman at ac comedy club there's
a couple guys that follow me on facebook
there's a couple guys that message me on
twitter and ask me questions about
comedy
it's your world guys don't let nobody
piss on your [__] leg and trust me
i know what you're going through i went
through it i
know what hate is i know what people
not wanting you i know how that feels
when somebody doesn't want you
i know exactly how that feels don't let
that deter you
hang in there hang in there and when
they're talking to you telling you
whatever just think how you're gonna
come back and shove your dick up their
ass in eight or nine years
think about how they're gonna suck your
dick and light your cigarette and tell
you you're the funniest person in the
world
even though you're not they're gonna say
that to you once you start selling
tickets
and making money and you get your first
little 20-minute special
wherever whatever is available next
netflix
hbo yahoo wait till they come around
that's why i always tell young comics
when they come to la they get a
commercial agent
get a commercial agent why joey so you
start booking
as soon as a club owner or a club booker
or club manager see you on tv
whether it's a commercial or you dress
up as a chicken
whatever the [__] it is as soon as they
see you on tv
they know they can't [__] with you
because
you booked a commercial and now that
commercial could turn into a movie
or a series or you could blow the [__]
up and that's what saved me in la
in 98 i booked those taco bell
commercials
and all those comedy club owners saw it
i kept booking
if you look at my imdb i booked early on
why to let them know i was going to be
[__] dangerous
because once they see you on a
commercial a video
a tv show they go let me treat this guy
differently
because if he did this he could do that
take that to the [__] bank i
love you guys thank you for watching
uncle joey's joint always representing
laughing [__] gas what do you think
about that huh you guys have been doing
great with the laughing
gas uh thank you very much
for [__] supporting me george perez
called me last night
said he loves it people are loving it my
friend brett who is taking jiu jitsu
lessons from
loves it it's a great [__] weed and i
love you guys i'm feeling a lot better
thank you for all the support and the
kind words you guys know i was
struggling
for like 11 months i put that [__]
behind me
uh like i said i had all this anxiety
they put a heart mind on me the anxiety
[__] disappeared i'm good tiptop my
goo
the teeth are okay my gums are turning
purple but what are you gonna do it
could be worse you know what i'm saying
this tooth is a little [__] up i bit
into a sandwich last night i started
bleeding
but this is all gonna be behind this
[__] soon guys
thank you for all your support thank you
for being on patreon
uh thank you for supporting the ice
cream shop and laughing gas
and i'll see you [__] wednesday
august [__] fourth can you believe
that
it's [__] august already [__]
the rent is due
i love you [__] stay black i'll be
back wednesday
with another fun-filled episode of the
joint thank you very much for watching
on a monday morning
i hope that this helps a lot of young
comics don't let nobody [__] crush
your dream
like i said while they're telling you
this you're thinking you're seeing
yourself [__] them in the ass and i'm
going
all right all right i'll write you the
check i love you guys have a great week
stay black
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening today
i loved going back and thinking about
seattle because uh
i didn't mention a lot of things during
[__] whatever during ryan sickler's
podcast
so i wanted to get out there i know
there's a lot of comics young comics
struggling right now with the clubs and
what the [__] going on but anyway
the joint is brought to you by zip
recruiter
listen people are hiring you want a job
everyone is hiring right now like i said
earlier millions of jobs will need to
get filled
as businesses keep reopening how do you
hire people fast
zip recruiter i don't care if you have
200 employees or eight employees
try zip recruiter for free you have
nothing to lose
here's the difference with zip recruiter
okay you just
you're not just posting a [__] job
for some [__] joe schmo to
show up zip recruiter has fancy
technology that finds the best people
for the job and it helps you get them it
tells you who's the most qualified
and invites them to apply it works
get two and a half times more candidates
this way
not just candidates but qualified
candidates
people who are going to make a
difference for your business
four to five employees who post on
ziprecruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day stop messing around you know we need
all the money we can right now
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free joey what do you think
free f-r-e-e at ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com joey
joey j o e y if you can't spell joey
you're not gonna get a [__] job
but zip recruit will still give you a
job try it for free
just by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey listen to me ziprecruiter is the
smartest
way to hire right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
joey and try zip recruiter for free the
joint is also
brought to you by blue chew can you
imagine going through life without a
[__]
tremendous boner blue chew can help
they're an online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis for a fraction of the cost
like i said in the top of the show i'm
58 i'm an old goat
i need [__] a little viagra from time
to time but you guys are saying joey i
i don't need it i'm a young guy i'm
slinging dick with three hands listen
you can't sling enough dick you could
take this any time
day and night and the process to get on
blue chew is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com you talk to
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved
bam you'll receive your prescription
within days
the best part of this it's all online
you don't got to see nobody no doctors
no awkward conversations no eye contact
no waiting online at the [__]
pharmacy it ships right to your door in
a discreet package
not even your mailman knows blue chew
tablets are made in the u.s of a
prepared and shipped directly it's way
cheaper than a pharmacy and just to add
to this
last wednesday i had to go to the heart
doctor you go in there an assistant
comes in
takes your blood pressure takes your
pulse asks you a couple questions
she asks you what medication you're on
and at the end she goes are you still in
the [__] viagra
my heart dropped that's a woman i got
embarrassed there's no embarrassment
with blue chew nobody to talk to this is
why i love blue chew
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to sling dick
blue chew can help and they've got a
special deal for you all right you try
blue chew
for free what are you talking about free
with promo code joey
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's it five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code joey to
receive your first month for free
and as always i want to thank bluetooth
for sponsoring the podcast
i want to thank bluetube i want to thank
ziprecruiter and i want to thank you
guys for always having our back
on a beautiful monday [__] morning
it's gonna be a great week
hang on to your seat belts we'll be back
wednesday same
[__] bat time to rock your [__]
world
i love you [__] have a great
monday and a great tuesday
and i'll see you wednesday stay black
cox smithers
[Music]
there you go
you